تقول شرطة ميامي إن شجاعة فتاة تبلغ من العمر ست سنوات
ربما أنقذت حياتها عندما
حاول رجل اختطافها خارج منزلها
الأسبوع الماضي، وفقًا للشرطة،
وكانت الفتاة تلعب مع أطفال آخرين
خارج مبنى شقتهم عندما
أمسكها شخص غريب فجأة وحاول.
لحملها بعيدًا، عضته بشدة لدرجة أنه
تركها تذهب، وأظهر مقطع فيديو أمني
المشتبه به وهو يتجول حول الفتاة،
وتعقبته شرطة حي الفتاة
واعتقلته، وبعد يومين
تحدثت الفتاة ووالدتها للصحفيين عن هذا
الحادث المخيف
عندما جاء وأمسك به.  هل
صرخت بنعم ثم ماذا فعلت
نعم ثم
ماذا بعد ذلك صفعني
وألقاني على الأرض أخبرتها لا
تتحدث مع الغرباء وإذا حدث أي شيء
فقط حاول التقاط شيء
قريب منها و  فقط اضربه
بها، من
فضلك قل أن المشتبه به البالغ من العمر 32 عامًا
اعترف بأنه هو في
فيديو المراقبة وهو محتجز بدون بيل
بتهمة الاختطاف وإساءة معاملة الأطفال